et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous aya
cissoko bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau au nom de tous les tiens publié
au seuil est votre troisième texte un
texte très puissant on va y revenir dans
un instant pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas ya six au qu il me faut
vous présentez d'aucun dirait que vous
êtes né de parents maliens immigrés que
votre mère était une analphabète que
vous avez grandi dans des quartiers dits
populaires à paris que vous êtes devenue
championne de boxe de monde du monde
trois fois à la force du poignet et du
point
ce voeu que vous êtes aujourd'hui aux
tris rien n'est faux vous me direz dans
ce que je viens de dire mais le propos
de votre livre et que vous êtes aussi et
peut être avant tout la fille de maciré
dansira et de sa guise sissoko
exactement donc c'est un livre sur la
transmission
un livre aussi en direction de ma fille
parce que c'est à elle que je parle dans
l' ouvrage
c'est aussi un livre pour réhabiliter
justement celles et ceux qui nous ont
précédés
aussi dira mafiques n'est pas la fille
de rien et de personne qu'elle s'inscrit
dans une histoire dans une filiation
et également parce qu'il ya énormément
de choses dans ce livre la nécessité
effectivement 2
qui devrait être la nôtre de s'ancrer
dans l'histoire pour pouvoir construire
aujourd'hui et demain il vous fallait
nommer vos parents et vos vos ancêtres
pour attester écrivez-vous de leur
humanité singulière pour choisir vos
héros et leur rendre la place qui est la
leur alors dans mon ouvrage
effectivement je cite continûment en
fait tous ceux à qui je fais référence
tous ceux à qui je rends hommage par
leur nom et prénom
justement cette identité atteste de leur
existence de leur filiation et par
extension de leur humanité
malheureusement nous sommes encore dans
un temps où certains individus doivent
d'une certaine manière
revendiqué cette humanité mes parents
effectivement enfin occuper des ddd
métier peu valorisé
enfin si ce qu'on appelle aussi les uns
visibiliser
de la france aussi de la narration et
donc oui il était nécessaire de dire ils
ont existé et ils ont réalisé de belles
et de grandes choses sans jamais
renoncer à leur dignité et donc ce livre
est effectivement s'adresser à leur
petite fille à celle de vos parents à
votre fille qui a 9 ans aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que vous vouliez
raconter ce parcours de vie publiquement
il raconté à el publiquement
lui raconter à elle enfin comme ma mère
le fut à son époque fait enfin en sont
en avance avant sa disparition je
maquille de mon devoir de transmission
d'une part parce que on ne sait je
pensais pas quand est-ce que que l'on va
disparaître et puis surtout c'est un
matériel que je voulais laisser à sa
disposition c'est à dire que je suis
aussi l'héritière d'une culture orale
donc bas qui risque de se perdre si
celle ci n'est pas fixe et enfin sur du
papier et donc c'est un matériel qui
sera sa disposition quand l'enfant quand
elle se sentira prête
à le lire ou et puis et puis de toute
façon fait il se peut qu'elles ne
veulent absolument pas s'y intéresser
mais en tout cas de mon enfin moi je
m'occupe de mon devoir de transmettre
disposera alors qu'il y avait tout gagné
en boxe vous dites que ce n'est pas ce
sport qui est violent mais c'est la vie
c'est ça aussi dont il est question dans
ce livre vous avez perdu prématurément
votre mère et votre petite soeur dans l
incendie criminel de votre immeuble puis
votre petit frère d'une méningite non
diagnostiquée il y a deux mots qui
reviennent beaucoup dans votre récit la
colère et la dignité l'une ne va pas
sans l'autre et ça vous avez mis un peu
de temps avant de le comprendre oui la
colère c'est un sentiment que j'ai
ressenti très très tôt très précocément
parce que jugée eu à faire face à des
gens justice enfant a des vues des
inégalités fin au racisme et aux
discriminations enfin très précocement
et donc oui le sentiment enfin le les
mots soient enfin qu' il est apparu très
rapidement ça a été la colère une colère
qui m'a longtemps habité que la boxe a
permis d'extérioriser
et puis l'écriture a pris le relais donc
mettre des mots sur cette colère et sur
la dignité on vous a dit long temps de
serrer les dents la dignité c'est un
corset fait donc c'est la dignité
signifie enfin nous on appelle ça le
d'amberfin c'est ainsi que ma mère me
l'a transmis dont qui signifie dignité
en bambara et oui c'est une sorte de
corset qui nous permet de tenir debout
deux oublis de ne jamais courbé l'échiné
et wii et qui nous permet aussi de nous
rappeler dans quelles histoires on
s'ancre et donc c'est voilà cette
histoire qui m'a été transmise par mes
parents ce que ça veut dire d'être noir
aujourd'hui en france et pour vous et
pour votre fille c'est de ça aussi dont
il est question dans ce livre vous le
disiez tout à l'heure vous dites que
vous vous dites que vous avez eu
longtemps honte de votre mère parce
qu'elle n'était pas blanche elle vient
de ça aussi votre colère qu'on vous a
empêché d'une certaine façon de voir de
voir ça de voir sa puissance ben c'est
oui enfin en tant qu'enfant
noir fait je n'ai pas pu jouir de cette
candeur qui de cette insouciance qui est
censé accompagner cet âge
parce que la société me renvoyer
effectivement que cette femme n'était
pas assez bien
qu'elle n'avait pas les codes qu'elle
n'avait pas l'école ne parlais pas la
langue elle était habillé en boubou
et donc oui j'ai eu honte de cette femme
avant de me rendre compte avec l'âge
avec l'expérience que cette femme était
extrêmement puissante
c'est une figure sacrificielle aussi
c'est à dire que elle met
continuellement des stratégies en place
elle se démène quotidiennement pour que
ses enfants les deux qui lui reste ne
manque de rien et je lui dois
je lui dois énormément enfin sans elle
je ne serai pas la femme que je suis
aujourd'hui
de ce livre il est question de ce que
votre couleur de peau et politique ici
en france c'est ce que vous écrivez le
racisme partout tout le temps
structurelles vous écrivez qu'il vous
attend toujours mais qui ne vous blesse
plus alors oui effectivement le
le graphisme qui émane des individus ne
me blesse plus dans le sens où j'ai un
sens de la répartie
j'ai un bon sens de la répartie donc je
sais me défendre après effectivement il
ya aussi ce racisme insidieux donc
institutionnel qui est beaucoup plus
difficile à déceler et qui conditionne
qui commande les trajectoires enfin
quasiment long terme d'une vie c'est à
dire selon le lieu où vous habitez ben
voila vous allez à telle école
fait une véritable rupture d'égalité en
france et quelle que soit la tension
sociale s'est alors
oui oui et effectivement c'est cette
expression effectivement que j'utilise
dans l' ouvrage la classe n'efface pas
la race dans le sens où voilà malgré le
parcours qui est le mien malgré les
réussites qui sont les miennes un
quelconque individu ben demain peu
m'interpeller dans la rue du sel fait ma
couleur de peau et c'est aussi être
exposés continûment à des discours
racistes à dernière nous n'avons
absolument pas été épargné lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle
et c'est ça cette réalité c'est à dire
alors je luis et
oui voilà je suis en colère et comme on
apprend à sa petite fille on faire face
à ça alors pour l'instant je lui
apprends strictement pas parce que une
fois de plus l'insouciance et quelque
chose enfin qui dont elle doit jouir
donc en tant que maman qui est mon
enfant je suis censé la protéger et donc
je lui en parle pas
mais je sais pertinemment qu'à un moment
donné de sa vie on lui posera cette
question qui semble comme ça anodine
mais quels sont tes origines tu viens
d'où tu viens d'où bah
alors que cet enfant est française et la
abou sall est là justement dans ce livre
tu viens d'où et dans l'histoire de
votre petite fille viennent semer les
différentes histoires celle de la
colonisation celle de l'éclat de l'
esclavage et celle de l'holocauste et
les du côté de son papa descendante dieu
de juifs ashkénazes venus d'ukraine en
partie décimée pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ce livre si c'est pour la lui
apprendre à être armés et à faire
cohabiter dans sa vie ses héritages là
alors c'est déjà lui dire que enfin sa
filiation enfin celles et ceux qui l'ont
précédé en fait la résistance qui l'ont
qu'ils ont déployés face à baho pire
voilà elle doit être un formidable
bagages elle doit s'appuyer dessus elle
doit s'appuyer sur ce passé et surtout
pour que tous les hommes restent des
hommes c'est à dire vu l'histoire qui
est la sienne dont elle est l'héritière
elle ne veut pas faim enfin
personnellement ce serait enfin une un
échec qui fait ainsi
whissell été amenés à appréhender enfin
les hommes tous les hommes avec mépris
avec arrogance avec dans tous les hommes
doivent rester des hommes quels qu'ils
soient d'où qu'ils viennent quelles que
soient leurs croyances
et un vous voilà c'est tout sera en tout
cas tous les combats doivent tendre vers
cette direction voilà vous dites que
votre projet de maman pour elle c'est
qu'elle se mette dans le dans le camp de
celui de la dignité en tout cas dans le
camp de celui de la dignité qu'elle
garde sa dignité dans le camp de ceux
ba qui oeuvrent pour le bien commun vous
écrivez à son endroit je ne peux
concevoir que ton existence se réduisent
à résister pourtant ce livre ce sont des
magnifiques portraits d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont résisté précisément je
suis parfaitement d'accord avec toi
enfin avec l'inde et que vous ça y est
avec vous mais la résistance est quelque
chose qui épuise les corps c'est quelque
chose qui abîme psychologiquement c'est
pour ça que enfin j aborde en filigrane
la santé mentale des personnages et ce
n'est pas ce qu'on veut pour pour nos
enfants enfin je répète les propos de
maciré nous aussi on a nos enfants comme
moi aussi j'aime ma fille est une fois
de plus enfin je le répète je veux que
ma fille profite de cette candeur de
cette insouciance qui a trait à cette
période de la vie
et fouillis et si j'aspire à la même
chose pour 8 ou les enfants quelques oui
quels qu'ils soient d'où qu'il vienne
maciré dansira et sa guise aux gosses
étaient vos parents aya cissoko ils sont
le fil de ce livre merci beaucoup de
nous parler d'eux dans ce livre est un
livre d'amour votre amour à vous pour
votre fille et les vôtres ceux qui sont
partis et ceux qui restent un livre sur
la transmission l'a dit sur la fragilité
des choses sur la colère et sur la
dignité sur la maternité c'est un texte
très puissant qui est sorti donc au
seuil c'est votre troisième texte et qui
clôt une forme de réflexion que vous
avez sur votre famille merci beaucoup
d'actes mangeant merci merci pas s'il
est revenue nous en parler